well airlines aviation and the whole
travel sector on their
knees have been crippled by the
coronavirus crisis
um passengers were hoping that the
government report was going to tell them
when they could go on holiday abroad
this summer that was the whole point of
it
but the report that came out the other
day was uh the government called it a
road map but i've never seen a road map
with all the destinations blanked out
we won't know until next month which
countries the governments say are on
this so-called
green list that it's okay to travel to
or on a red list or an amber list
people are going to have to take
expensive tests there may be
queuing at at airports to go on holiday
so
the other day the government secretary
of state said for the first time
people can start thinking about their
summer holidays well
people actually want to know when they
can go and where they can go those are
the answers we need
those are the points i'll be raising
this morning i suppose luke the problem
with that is it is it's it's data
pacific it all depends on what is
happening in these countries at any
given point in time
yeah i mean i agree that uh with brian's
points there uh
in the main i think overall he's welcome
that the government has restated the
ambition to
to restart international travel as soon
as possible hopefully by the 17th of may
it is welcome in principle that we're
getting a traffic light system we've all
been calling for
uh in the industry a risk-based approach
to the restart of international travel
but as brian says there
really is a lack of detail within the
report that came out from the global
travel task force
and the industry i think does feel an
overriding sense of frustration with
that lack of detail
we particularly need to know the kind of
criteria of how countries are going to
be assessed so not
in early may but to not even know what
the criteria behind that are at this
point i think many in the industry
were disappointed not to get more
information on that and again as brian
alluded to
testing is going to be a major barrier
to travel this summer we need the
government to engage with the insurance
how we can bring down the cost of
testing
and indeed to look at the approach
that's being followed anyway within the
within the global travel task force
report particularly for low-risk
countries we cannot understand why
countries in the green
category should require a pcr test uh we
believe a double kind of lateral flow
uh test approach would be a more
proportionate
approach to follow in in that category
yes
but i mean both raising concerns about
the testing and in terms of
do you think it's a cost problem brian
for a lot of people as much as anything
else i've got to be honest because we're
all getting our sort of tests for free
when we need one
whether it's pcr or lateral flow at the
moment i mean i'm not aware how much a
pcr
test would actually cost if i wanted to
go on holiday
well there's a whole range of prices
being being quoted i think the average
cost is about 120 pounds per person
last night somebody told me they'd seen
somewhere that offers quite a
quite a cheap um test and i looked that
up and i didn't think it was very
reputable company and that's a
danger of course that people go looking
for cheap ways of
of getting tests but i think if the
government's demanding these tests the
government should be subsidizing them
to make the price reasonable and i think
government should kick-start the whole
of international travel by
offering all the tests free to our
frontline
key workers they they deserve that they
deserve a holiday
it would be a really good way to get
this initiative underway yeah you can
certainly see how that would be
problematic for a you know a family of
four what have you having to pay for
for four of those in terms of of outer's
position luke
in all of this i mean and the play it
applies to both of you
but i guess the problem is with with the
the lack of clarity over how this
roadmap is going to
work moving forward means i guess people
just aren't booking
at the moment i mean it's it who wants
to take the risk
yeah well firstly on the testing point
just just quickly i think it is
important to point out it's not just the
cost of course which we do need
government to
to intervene and kind of try and bring
that down but also
the report doesn't say anything about
the treatment of vaccinated individuals
and whether or not they will be exempted
from testing requirements which seems to
be
again a proportionate approach it
doesn't talk about whether children will
require a test or not
but looking at bookings of holidays i
mean after this position there is that
people can continue to book a holiday if
you're booking a package
holiday then you are guaranteed to to
either receive
your holiday a alternative if if you're
unable to go to the destination perhaps
that you have picked but still want to
travel which we know many people will
want to do
after a year perhaps not getting away
and if none of that can happen then you
will of course receive a refund there is
the package travel regulations you are
you are
protected financially when you book a
package holiday so we would hope that
people
are feeling confident enough to still go
out there and book at this time
brian just how much is the aviation
industry on its knees
at this time i mean for a lot of us we
we hear about it but because we're not
we're not getting on a plane so we don't
think about it too much so people like
you actually in the business
how difficult has it been and how how
problematic is it going to be
to try and get the industry back up and
running
well flying is 85
down on pre-pandemic levels passenger
numbers are 95
down we've seen the collapse of two
airlines
flybe and norwegian air uk we've seen
thousands and thousands of job losses
i can look out my office window here to
my right and see a quiet heathrow
with a flight every 30 minutes whereas
it used to be every 30 seconds
uh it's very hard to describe the the
depth of the
recession the crisis that aviation and
the whole travel sector
is in and that's why we've been shouting
and screaming really
for government to give us a way out of
this and if they're not going to if
they're going to say it's too dangerous
too risky
fine in that case step in and help this
industry
which is vital to the whole uk economy i
i just wonder luke
as you prepare to to face uh this
committee today
do you think they're going to listen to
you do you think you're giving evidence
is going to make any difference
well i i certainly hope so i mean as
brian was saying you know it's been a
very tough year for everyone in the
travel industry travel agents tour
operators travel management companies
that have to represent
revenue down by around 90 uh
across the year uh we know that you know
around 80 000 people more than 80 000
people in the outbound travel sector
have lost
their jobs uh the industry does need a
road map to recovery and we do need
uh mps to listen to what is being said
today and as brian said you know if we
don't get
uh that roadmap to recovery and what the
report does make clear is we are facing
many months of constraints on the travel
industry then what is also needed is
is uh tailored financial support for for
those operating in the international
travel sector in the way that other
sectors of the uk economy have been
supported and that's another point that
we will be making today and that we hope
mps and indeed the government will act
upon